- I totally had a crush on Hans Solo,
but Hans Solo was already taken.
Now I just wanna watch Star Wars.
In this pillow fort.
Right now.
- We've never made a
blanket fort together.
- No, we haven't reached that point
in our relationship yet.
- [Girl in black] No.
- [Girl on right] This is
gonna be the best blanket fort.
Ever.
- My forte was umbrella forts.
- Ooooh!
- She's actually gonna be
the one building the fort
and we're just gonna watch.
- Ready, set.
- [Both] Go!
- No get up, get up, go!
- Maybe if we just like flank either side.
- [Girl on right] Yes.
- We need a bunny.
- Here's what I'm gonna do, Quinta.
- Well, first things first.
We need to make the floor cushy.
- [Girl on right] I'm
putting the sheets over here.
- [Girl swinging pillow] Get out!
Out!
- [Voiceover] How's it goin' smells?
- It's good, it's good.
♫ Twinkle twinkle little star ♫
- It's gettin' weird quick!
(glute slapping)
- [Girl bent over] Ow! (laughs)
- How do you sing it in Chinese?
- (sings in Chinese)
- Oh, that's actually really cute!
- [Girl in black] I know.
- [Voiceover] Anyone can join in
our fort.
- [Voiceover] Anyone can join.
- [Voiceover] Being an
adult sucks sometimes.
- [Voiceover] She's just chillin'.
You're not even helping us!
- Got some whale on dog action.
- [Voiceover] No one will
ever be able to find us.
- [Voiceover] No one will know.
- Should it just be Fort Dino?
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- Starlands.
- [Voiceover] Starlands.
Welcome to Starland.
- Goodbye.
- [All] Yoo hoo!
(laughing)
- Why don't we do this more often?
- Yeah, we should.
- We got hot chocolate!
- Hot chocolate!
- [Girl on left] Woooow!
- [Girl on right] Dude, you got like
50 billion, trillion
marshmallows in there.
- Oh!
Did you know it's my birthday today?
- I just need a really big book now.
- If we lay back, we
can look at the stars.
- Yeah, it's the same universe.
Of course we're looking at the same stars!
- Oh, we also need like
a no boys allowed sign.
- What kind of noise does a octopus make?
- Glug, glug, glug,
glug, glug, glug, glug.
- I wanted to be exactly
what I am right now.
- When I was growing up
I wanted to become a NASCAR driver.
- Really?
- [Girl on right] Yeah.
- [Girl in middle] That
explains the way you drive.
- [Voiceover] I think this makes me think
maybe I take my life a
little too seriously.
- [Voiceover] Same.
(whimsical music)